c'est quoi le particularisme alsacien
car oui vraiment l'alsace est différente
à bien des égards des autres régions
françaises
cette différence c'est un mélange
d'histoire de culture et de droit et
s'il ya bien un symbole de ce
particularisme régional c'est celui du
dialecte le directeur pour une large
part dans la personnalité longtemps
parlé dans une très grande majorité de
familles le dialecte a façonné la
culture alsacienne
mais ce dialecte n'est pas enseignée à
l'école conséquence de moins en moins de
jeunes le parle parce que chez ma
grand-mère tous à toutes les
conversations se font en alsace alors
j'arrive à l'étude monsieur ou j'aiderai
pour l'heure française mais qu'ils
parlent le dialecte ou non les alsaciens
sont tous sensibles à l'histoire
mouvementée de leur région conquise par
la france de louis xiv
l'alsace est ensuite annexée par
l'allemagne de 1871 à 1918
c'est en raison de cette longue période
germanique que l'alsace aujourd'hui
n'est pas laïque mais soumise au régime
du concordat du nom de ce traité signé
par bonaparte
l'état reconnaît et organise les
religions catholique protestante et
israélites
c'est l'état qui paie les écrire oui
monsieur c'est exact les curés ainsi que
les pasteurs et les rabbins sont
rémunérés par le ministère de
l'intérieur comme un crs si vous voulez
nos contrées veillant au maintien de
l'ordre par et pris le relais dans les
forces morales du pays
la morale religieuse on la retrouve
jusque sur les bancs de l'école publique
des cours de religion facultatif sont
ouverts à tous les élèves un
particularisme religieux alsacien qu'on
retrouve aussi dans le calendrier avec
deux jours fériés en plus
quoi étonner les touristes lendemain de
noël ferrié
uniquement ici en trois jours en fait
voilà que vous en pensez quoi
j'aime bien ma chance mais le
particularisme ne s'arrête pas là en
alsace la sécurité sociale est plus
généreuse que dans les autres régions de
l'hexagone
un autre héritage de l'époque allemande
son taux de remboursement est très
avantageux 90% d'une consultation chez
le médecin par exemple contre 70 % dans
le reste de la france
les alsaciens sont attachés à ces
particularismes culturels religieux et
sociaux il les considère comme
l'héritage de l'art histoire et pour
certains ça peut même être un lien entre
france et allemagne
comme le dit l'homme de lettres alsacien
germain muller
un trait d'union jusque nous voudrions
être un trait d'union des centres de
culture
[Musique]